the Conservatives are in total disarray
so this should be a great time for the
opposition any sort of decently properly
organized labour party would be taking
the toys apart in both the political
debate and in the polls but where's the
Labour Party the answer is nowhere
instead of taking the government to the
cleaners they like the toys are tearing
themselves apart not over a profound
issue like breaks in but of
anti-semitism and as you wish Jeremy
Corbyn could and should have sorted
months and months ago when Frank field
described some of the hard left who
increasingly control the labour party is
intolerant nasty thugs and bullies I
know from my own experience that is
right but an even greater failing of the
hard left is that they have always had a
self-destruct button when faced with any
chance of success I've always had the
ability to snatch defeat from the jaws
which is exactly what they've been doing
this summer
[Music]
you know I picked up an interesting
thing over these last few weeks and some
of the corridors of power I'm gonna put
this to you Greg undoubtedly as we've
just discussed mrs. Mayer's in enormous
trouble within a conservative party
there are some who would say that mr.
Corbett's handling of the anti-semitism
issue and other issues with the no party
and the fact that he tried to insert
that caveat during the week when they
had that says he actually potentially is
possibly in as much danger within his
own party as mrs. Mayer's within hers
and they're both heading on to pretty
ugly conferences great I think that's
true but I'm not sure how you how they
get rid of it which I can see how the
concern I'm gonna get rid of mrs. mate I
don't know cause he had Miliband divides
labour Katya genuinely don't know how
you get rid of yeah but it's a very
strange time when actually the political
leadership in this country is months
months ago months ago that actually many
people in the Labour Party they don't
want to be the government they just want
to be a sort of force of opposition and
an angry but do you think that's
changing I think the
I mean you John McDonald they said that
Charles get in the summer and he quite
clearly has been annoyed by that Corbett
has assaulted this out the anti-semitic
ridiculous it's interesting at that
meeting the other day we're talking
about them voting for the caveat which
was a get out clause for anti-semitism
but anyway it's it that's the first time
Corbin has never had the room where he's
always had everyone on side this is me
and and a couple of weeks before both
both MacDonald and John Landsman the
founder of momentum who was a Jew you
know these two guys are saying to him
you have to sort this out of media so
when they're saying that you know he's
got a problem but I think the problem
with the left isn't it that they have a
problem and they refuse to see it it's
like the anti-semitism thing they've
refused to acknowledge that this is a
problem you know you have that that
idiot Will's Minh Peter Wilson who was
voted back onto the NAC last week you
have him saying there I've never seen
anti-semitism in the party it's
happening to Margaret Hodge writ large
at the moment and yet they're saying we
don't say that has been the problem all
along and if there is a problem they
blame other people they're blaming the
right-wing media for the anti-semitism
they're denying it of one thing ii am
writing it just laughing at frank field
you know the MP who's there tried to
deselect let's see we must be free from
the intolerance which has spread from
that debate or perhaps gone up from the
local parties where small groups of
people think by shouting shouting
hollering and doing god knows well they
can bully their way to success i mean
you have to say i think some of the
frank field is seen in the labor party
is one of these people who could have a
a disagreement in the room when he's out
yet but also anyone who's ever spin in
the local party a period of time knows
as this chunk of the far-left
who is exactly right yeah they think let
me just say Rach I promise back that we
must just get what mr. Corbyn said as
recently as last month about the
anti-semitic issue and he goes as
follows I do acknowledge there is a real
problem that labor is working to
overcome and I
set that if any part of our national
community feels threatened anxious or
vulnerable not only must that be taken
at face value but we must ensure all
those fears are put to rest
I want Jewish people to feel at home in
the labor party be able to play their
full part in our work to take our
country which here is actions match
their his words I mean speaking as
someone who sort of sat around watching
this over the summer it was a bit like
Gary Lineker his definition of a
football match you know 22 men kick a
ball around for 90 minutes and the
Germans win with this it's two months of
Rage on Twitter and their momentum wins
it's been absolutely a futile own goal
and you have to wonder why what was
potentially a government in Waiting
consumed itself over a pointless and
destructive and terribly damaging Rao
over racism but we have an explanation
as to why they did this from Liam Young
anti racism is incredibly important to
the Labour Party and to Labour Party
members and I believe that it's actually
really important that we do get this
right and we get it right on both sides
got this right in turn I think in some
ways that demeans the argument about
anti racism because we could have got on
to attacking the Tories on brexit and so
on but I think it's actually right that
the Labour Party sorts this out properly
on both sides and we don't we don't
undermine how important as the race is
so it's not sorted out and we just might
just finish by saying that in terms of
traction on this issue we're only 5
percent of the public actually noticed
this anti-semitism row that has taken
there the Labour Party sees
anti-semitism as a as a lesser form of
evil that because they don't see the
Jews is a legitimate race and so they
they they give much more credence to
racism directed at other minority groups
and they don't judge people you can't
let the Labour Party versus recruits its
whom have always been obsessed about
Palestine and war which is insisted that
Israel is a mess of support I think it's
jeremy corbyn's a problem in this whole
thing yes I don't think of Jeremy Corbyn
didn't leave the Labour Party we'd have
a Labour government overs now Jeremy
Corbyn his classic of the left isn't it
then you can never you can never be
pragmatic you can never say all right
this is a real issue but let's park it
and let's
get on with the what matters to the
public they can never do that little if
they I mean they really never been in
the like button and seen the left
yeah the different sections the left
they spent more time trying to defeat
each other but they do you said you'd
seen the bullying that Frank field
referred to all the nastiest what do you
recall them from your experiences i well
there were always trotskyist groups that
came in and out of the Labour Party and
one of the periods in which they came in
they were always extremely unpleasant to
whoever was in control always I mean no
it's almost I mean far-right it's the
same let's not kid ourselves the far I
do you exactly the similar the far right
moving back into the Tory Party they
will be deeply unpleasant but you know
you said before that the Labour Party
issued a statement saying they're gonna
protect the Jewish people within the
party that's simply not true there's a
there's a story in the papers today
saying four out of ten Jewish people
would leave this country of Corbyn
became p.m. now that's shocking and Lord
Sachs the chief rabbi made us he made a
statement last week and and he just said
that he thinks korban is more evil you
know Cowley says he thinks that caught
the speeches Corbin have made recently
are are more evil than the river of
blood speech because they are more
divisive and and Sachs said this is an
interest may said Jews have been in this
country for 362 years and never before
has there been a situation where they
are asking themselves is this the
country to bring their kids up in which
is shocking it's shocking he's the man
I'd be kinder to Jacobi than that I
don't think he is auntie's I don't I
think his problem he's surrounded by
people who are yes I surround about some
people of Israel yes yeah that's the
basic from you and the foundation but is
so typical of the people of the land
they can't let anything go
they can't say all right we'll partly I
do with the locations they should be
fighting your position there yeah